stop mépris lycée en colère voici les
messages que proclament les
contestataires sur les banderoles
déployées devant le ds d eux n la
direction des services départementaux de
l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui on est sur une mobilisation
dans le cadre de la préparation de
rentrée 2010 neuf donc les moyens pour
faire fonctionner les établissements à
la rentrée sont arrivés dans les
établissements et donc les personnes qui
sont rassemblés derrière moi et qui se
manifestent sont là pour réclamer
davantage de moyens pour préparer leur
rentrée professeurs et parents inquiet
de la dotation horaire globale
ce nombre d'heures d'enseignement
attribué par établissement qui sert à
réaliser la répartition des classes
cette année la dotation horaire globale
qui a été allouée a été diminué ce qui
fait que une classe va être supprimé je
pense qu'on n'a pas même enseignement
quand on est 26 élèves dans une classe
où quand on est 31 32
l'enseignant ne peut pas avoir la même
attention avec tous les élèves mais bon
ça devient des enseignements plus
difficile
motivée non résigné les enseignants
déplorent la dégradation des conditions
d'enseignement et veulent le faire
entendre aux représentants de la déesse
des yens ce qui risque de disparaître en
tout cas dé diminuer ses les dispositifs
dettes qui sont proposées aux élèves en
terme de dédoublement par exemple pour
les matières expérimentales ou des
dédoublements avec des groupes de
besoins dans
en mathématiques en français on pourra
certainement proposer moins que ce qu'on
propose aujourd'hui l'insuffisance des
dotations se manifeste également par des
suppressions de postes pour le
département des yvelines on estime que
c'est environ une trentaine de postes à
peu près 13 13 en collège et aux 18 ans
lycée neuf établissements demandé à être
reçus par la direction des services
départementaux de l'éducation nationale
en fin d'après midi les enseignants
envisagent d'autres actions avec le
soutien des parents
[Musique]